first big burning question I've had
since Tiff is what was that response
like for you was there any little piece
of you that knew that audiences were
going to embrace it that wholeheartedly
no of course not I'm I'm an artist I'm
so
insecure you call yourself an artist I
was watching another interview you did
where you were explaining how it was
very difficult to embrace calling
yourself an artist and also a
professional artist so now after an emem
win and making your first feature do you
consider yourself a professional artist
yes I do but it doesn't that that has
nothing to do with my insecurity I'm
absolutely a professional artist but I'm
still terrified all the time that people
are going to hate what I do it's like
it's really the sort of like artist's
way I have a I have a good friend who is
talking about this recently it's the
artist way to to think like this is
terrible oh my God this is awful I need
millions of people to see this awful
thing that I've done it's this cognitive
dissonance of really feeling like oh man
I'm not sure if this is going to be good
but I need to show this to a lot of
people to see if they think it's good so
uh I was not expecting that response in
Tiff I I certainly was um I was
terrified going into it in fact I there
was a part of me that didn't want to sit
through it because I was so afraid that
it was going to fall flat um but you
know within about 10 minutes I when I
heard the sort of audience erupt in
laughter and the places that I wanted
them to laugh and really responding to
the material that to me was uh it
allowed me to to calm down a little bit
and enjoy the experience you better
enjoy what's coming your way right now I
love the fact that a film could evolve
every step of the way like writing
filming editing but then also how it
evolves again when an audience receives
it so given that mentality is there
anything about your own movie that feels
like it plays stronger than ever because
of how people responded you never
realized it before but they really took
to it and now you love it even more yeah
I think that it's I think that the thing
that I was very excited about was seeing
how many different kinds of people are
appreciating appreci ating it you know I
think that for me I really wanted to
make a movie that felt big tent I didn't
want to make a movie that felt like it
was just for people on the coast and in
New York and La I really wanted to make
a movie that felt like anybody could
come in here and experience it and find
something to leave that they that they
enjoyed and so we've shown the movie
around the world now we've shown the
movie in you know at fancy film
festivals at colleges to predominately
black audiences predominately white
audiences older people younger people
and we've just had such a really great
response from every every kind of person
across the Spectrum and that's really
happy that that makes me really happy
I'm I'm excited that we're releasing it
around Christmas time around the
holidays so that people can go with
their whole families because I really do
think that there's something for
everybody in there and then and it
leaves you with you leave with a smile
on your face you know and then I really
wanted to make a movie that didn't feel
like it was lecturing or or like you
were coming in to sit through like a
college seminar that was going to leave
you kind of morose when you left I think
it's kind of a feel-good movie in a in a
way that I that I sort of didn't know if
people were going to accept it that way
and so I've been delighted to see that
they have been one of my favorite things
in the world is when I get to bring my
favorite films home to my family and
this movie was nerov family approved
everyone loved it and I love when we can
all love things together just makes me
happy absolutely I want to go back to
the beginning with a question here
because I was reading that peral turned
down a whole bunch of uh interest in
terms of turning a raser into a feature
film do you know why he gave you the
go-ahead was there anything about you
and your specific pitch that set it
apart I don't know I think that we've
never really discussed that exactly but
I think that one of the I think that one
of the great things about pel is that
he's just a real consumate artist he
just really he doesn't care about money
he doesn't care about Fame he doesn't
care about sort of like being in the
public eye he just really cares about
art and being passionate about the art
and so we spoke on the phone for about a
half an hour he asked me why I was
passionate about it he asked me what I
what I intended what kind of movie I
wanted to make and then incredibly he
gave me the rights for free to the book
he said he said go ahead he said right
he said I'll give you the rights for 6
months for free go write a script and if
anything comes of it then you can can
pay me back when you sell it and so he
is just uh you know for those people who
don't know you know legal battles and
sort of like the legal discussions about
getting rights for something to adapt
can take months sometimes years and so
just his willingness to give it to me
for free uh it meant the world I'll be
forever indebted to him for that kind of
wish the process went like that a little
more often I feel like we'd be like
buried in high quality films right now
so again this is your first feature but
just so everyone knows you're an Emmy
winner you have tons of experience of
all of your series writing and producing
experience which particular show did you
find coming in handy most in terms of
what it takes to tackle a feature film
instead oh God I think that something
that really helped me with the writing
experience was Watchmen and I think that
uh you know Watchmen was the first
really uh I'm trying to I think it's the
only TV adaptation no that's not true
it's but it was the first big TV
adaptation I also did a show called
station 11 that was an ad yeah thank you
thank you and so the but the thing that
I took from Watchmen the adaptation of
Watchmen was that that Damon always
talked about was that you know the key
to a great adaptation isn't necessarily
maintaining um you know maintaining fty
to the text of the of the script and I'm
sorry the text of the novel and the sort
of like full characters and stuff that
come from that story the key to sort of
a good adaptation and and one that
doesn't feel bloodless is is keeping the
spirit and the essence and the feeling
of the of the original text alive and so
to
me although there's some big departures
from the novel that we take uh in the
movie what I tried to do is keep the
spirit of the novel alive and keep
peral's original ideas alive so for
instance one of the you know the
epigraph of the novel is this is this uh
uh Latin phrase that I was unfamiliar
with and apparently it's used in
relationship to complex mathematics and
and the rough translation is I offer no
hypothesis and so to me the sort of
suggestion there was that I couldn't
make a movie that felt didactic that I
couldn't make a movie that felt like
here's the here's the moral lesson that
you take from this and here's the good
guys and here's the bad guys it felt
like my responsibility was was to make a
movie that that gave you some scenarios
and gave you some interesting characters
and then allowed you to walk away and
sort of feel about it how you want to
feel about it and so that to me was was
a was one of the main lessons that I
took from watching was just make an
adaptation that feels like of a piece
with the original text while also you
know doing some slashing and burning in
order to make a different piece of art
that you feel like you need to make such
great uh success in that respect I have
to ask you about working with your
Ensemble here because correct me if I'm
wrong but I believe this is your first
time directing actors this is my first
time directing anything yeah what is
something about collaborating with
Jeffree Sterling Erica and the rest of
the uh the rest of the cast here that
taught you something about what it means
to be an actor's director that you plan
to take with you to Future films or
shows I think it's helping the actors
find what is real about the character
that can pertain to their lives right
and so I think that it's sometimes about
saying like what's something here that's
more interesting than the role might
suggest right because there are there
are Parts in the movie that are I mean
there's Parts in every movie that are
smaller than sort of the smaller than
other roles and I think that sort of in
order to really get good actors to to
take those kinds of roles it's to it's
to help them understand this the the
importance of this and sort of like the
foundational nature of this character on
which all the other story is built right
and so it's letting them know like I
understand that you sort of like feel
different than this person might feel
but here's what goes on in your life
that sort of like might help you
understand this character a little bit
more and here's something that sort of
like makes me passionate about this
character that that sort of like might
help you to understand who this
character is a little more so you know
there's a lot of stuff in this movie
that that uh is is taken from my
personal life and sort of like my own
struggles with my personal and
professional life that sometimes I let
the I let the actors in on to say you
know here's what happened in my life
that made me write this character this
way that helpfully maybe maybe helps you
understand emotionally what this
character is doing and why they want to
why they want to live the their life the
way that they live their life and so I
think that that just is important to me
is to help everybody feel passionate
about it I think that this was a movie
that had um a lot of people passionate
and you know as I said I I had never
directed anything before so I didn't
have a reference point for that but
Jeffrey Jeffrey told me this thing that
I thought was really special where he
said he said you know being on a set you
can tell uh when people feel passionate
about what they're making and feel proud
of what they're making he said you can
see it them the way that they work are
they working as hardly as hard as they
can are they are they um you know are
they sort of being as productive as
possible are they sort of like working
in collaboration with other other other
other people sort of in a very healthy
way he said these are things that let
you know that people on set feel like
they're making something special and he
was like and I saw that from the first
day on set is that everybody felt like
they were making something special and
so for me as as somebody who never
directed anything before and didn't have
that reference point that meant the
world to me to hear him say that that
that sort of you can just tell by the
way that people work on set that they
feel like they're part of something that
feels good and so hopefully that that
that is that is reflected in the film
because there was a lot of love and joy
on set and we wanted to put it into the
movie 100% is Canen confirm
congratulations thank you so
much